There are thousands
upon thousands of Hindu temples in India.
This one is special. Because in many ways
it is emblematic of how polarized
the country has become
under Prime Minister Narendra Modi.
And it is at the heart of his reelection
efforts.
It has been three years
since the ground was broken
on the Ram Temple here in Ayodhya.
But the history of the site
is a lot longer
and more complicated than those numbers
suggest.
As India prepares
for a national election,
the structure
on the banks of the River Sarayu
shows how Modi's Bharatiya Janata Party
has become a seemingly
unstoppable electoral machine,
and it could help Modi fundamentally
change the world's most populous country.
Construction here in Ayodhya is nonstop,
as thousands of workers
race to complete the temple.
The city in northern India has become one
of the most popular Hindu pilgrimage
destinations, and it has a significance
dating back thousands of years.
That is when ancient scriptures
started citing it as the birthplace.
of Ram.
In Hinduism, Ram is one of the most widely
worshiped deities.
He's a hero of one of the religion's
two epics, the Ramayana.
Born a prince of Ayodhya, the tale recounts
his exile
and then his victory over
the forces of evil.
He is seen as the embodiment of all that is
good.
The ideal man.
For all those reasons and more,
it is a convenient association
for the Prime Minister.
Modi has become India's
most powerful leader in decades
by pushing Hindu nationalism or Hindutva.
IIt is a strand of politics
that conflates Hindu
religious identity and policy.
And it seeks to move India away
from the secular politics of its past,
instead forging
a nation for the majority
Hindu population.
Ayodhya has become
a controversial focus of Hindu
nationalism.
For the best part of 500 years,
the temple was the site of a mosque,
the Babri Masjid.
In 1992,
thousands of Hindus overwhelmed
security forces to demolish the mosque.
It was a political earthquake
that saw thousands die
in the riots that followed.
The quest to build a new temple galvanized
the Hindu nationalist movement.
In his 2014 election
campaign, he made a number of promises
to crack down on corruption,
develop the economy, introduce
a uniform civil code,
end the autonomy of India's only
Muslim majority state, Jammu and Kashmir,
and significantly build the Ram Temple.
But the last decade in power
has been challenging at times,
even as India's economy continues
to grow at a rapid rate.
That growth hasn't benefited
everyone uniformly
and unemployed moment remains
stubbornly high.
Modi has delivered
on some of his more contentious promises.
Scrapping Kashmir's autonomy
and now building this temple.
These are policies
that have helped Modi
overcome other electoral concerns.
Take the most
recent elections in November,
when key bellwether states,
including Madhya Pradesh, Rajasthan
and Chhattisgarh went to the polls.
Opposition Leader Rahul Gandhi
and his Indian National Congress
had been hopeful of
capitalizing on
some of Modi's
perceived weaknesses to make inroads.
There was a sense
before the vote that support among farmers
and women,
two of BJP's core constituencies,
might be waning.
Neetu Patel is a former schoolteacher
who is now a homemaker.
After years voting for the BJP,
she voted for Gandhi's
National Congress in November.
Patel was particularly
worried about inflation,
which remained high in November,
For about 70% of India's rural households,
agriculture is still the sole livelihood.
Modi promised to double farm income
when seeking his second term.
Tulsiram Patidar
owns a large farm around Bhopal.
Even so, it's taken
and time for Patidar
to come around to Gandhi and the Congress.
When the election
results landed on December 3rd,
the BJP retained power in Madhya Pradesh
and wrested control of the state
legislature
from the Indian National Congress
in both Rajasthan and Chattisgarh.
The opposition political parties, despite
their best efforts, have not been able
to challenge or question Modi's
credibility in the eyes of the people.
This is something which Rahul Gandhi
never understood, that holding
a position of power
or holding a state office
has a natural tendency
of introducing a charisma in you
which has benefited Narendra Modi
in building up his profile.
As concerns about unemployment
and corruption persist in some quarters,
the Indian Prime Minister
has taken advantage of rising nationalism,
which is also taking
hold in other parts of the world,
and the Ram Temple stands
as an example of that.
That Modi represents
the interest of all Hindus is, of course,
hotly contested by his opponents,
not least Rahul Gandhi.
There's nothing Hindu about what
the BJP does.
They are not Hindu nationalists.
They are nothing to do with Hinduism.
Since we are in a transition period
from the old fashioned
secular politics to a majoritian politics,
there are a lot of people
who are sympathizers
and supporters of the old ways.
They are very disturbed
by this political polarization.
They think that, something
fundamentally disruptive
is being unleashed by the present regime.
The temple won't be completed
for a few years.
And yet Modi is opening it in
January 2024,
just months before a general election.
An electoral
victory might let his government pursue
an agenda
that could include more temples
on disputed sites,
a national register of citizens
and a law that makes it harder for Muslims
to demonstrate
that they are Indian citizens,
steps that could cement India's move away
from the secular politics of its past.